good morning John I can already hear the
music building up beneath me so I should
probably just stop talking this song is
about quarks I wrote it
it's called strange charm a cork is a
fundamental constituent of matter
observed in 1968 through people asking
scattered we found that protons aren't
as simple as we thought we thought they
were solid particles but they are not
protons and factor' made up of three
separate pieces it just gets more
confusing as our knowledge increases but
that is what at work is it's a piece of
a proton and they also make up other
things including the neutron over down
strange
electrons and photons
exist things made up of works including
protons and neutrons are composite
particles that physicists call hadrons
many types of hadrons are theoretically
described but most exist for only very
brief amounts of time courts have
electric charge color charge mass and
spin and half in color charns makes is
solely inside of other kinds of
particles and cannot exist alone which
is what works have never been studied on
their own down strange charm not bottom
if you don't know water
you still got a man with lakhan's and
bosons unless something unless they make
up everything that we can see you man we
know exist course can join together in
two different ways
baryons and mesons but most instantly
decay if a particle has three works then
it's a very on if there's one more can
an antique work than it is a maze on
these tiny bits of matter a part of
almost everything and there is no
unified theory to make it less confusing
but the fact that we've identified that
they exist it always so goddamn
remarkable that I just sit in Otto up
down strange charm not bottom if you
don't know water quark is it don't
matter you still gotta man with let Hans
and bosons unless something's amiss they
make up everything that we can see in
that we know exists I like that song
that's a good song I hope that you all
enjoyed it too and you can listen to it
anytime by going to dftba slash quarks
and that's possible because my friend
Sam and my friend Alan worked their
butts off to create dftba a URL
shortening service that reminds you and
all the people that you tweet to to not
forget to be awesome so yes you can have
your own dftba URL right now I have to
do is go to dftba it's very exciting
it's just one more way that
nerdfighteria is taking over the
Internet John don't forget to be awesome
and I will see you on Friday
you